what about some of the myths to do with
entrepreneurial success
oh yeah
so
entrepreneurial success there's this
famous idea that entrepreneurs are young
so like mark zuckerberg
started facebook when he was
uh steve jobs was 20 started apple uh
bill gates 19 we started microsoft these
are kind of the most famous
entrepreneurs in the world
and
i think people think uh they're also the
most famous entrepreneurs featured in
the media so they've done studies of the
entrepreneurs in magazines and like the
median age is 27 or something so people
just love telling the stories of these
young people when you actually look at
the data of the entire universe of
entrepreneurs
uh the average successful entrepreneur
is 42
and the odds of an entrepreneur
succeeding
increase until the age of 60.
uh they which shocks me like you don't
think of a 60 year old like that's the
total opposite of a successful
entrepreneur and the other and like what
it turns out is there's pretty much a
formula for being a successful
entrepreneur you just get really deep
into the nitty-gritty of a field for
many many years
and then you branch out on your own when
you're ready uh which again goes against
a lot of stereotypes a lot of
stereotypes like just come from the
outside knowing nothing when you're
18 and it's not true like if you want to
be an entrepreneur the best path is like
take it slow
under learn about a field work as an
employee prove your worth as an employee
and then like learn some you'll learn
something very particular about
that field and you really know what to
do uh when you're ready so well yeah
it's it's such a compelling narrative
that outsiders edge right the elon musk
he never did a thing before so from
first principles he's gonna do whatever
and you go well yeah but the guys that
elon got to design batteries have
probably spent their entire lives
designing batteries you know he didn't
get he didn't get some dude that did
woodwork
for the last for the last 20 years and
you talk about uh paul graham as well
and that
was it the marginal
marginal edge or something as well yeah
yeah power the margin all right paul
graham at this this essay i'm a huge
paul graham fan but this essay like
that's an advantage to being a bad
employee because if you're a good
employee
you're not going to fit in
entrepreneurship and it's not true in
the data at all the best entrepreneurs
like earn the in the 99.9 percentile of
income before they started their
business
uh so
uh like i think a problem a problem with
understanding how the world works
is like
some ideas are almost too compelling
that they fool us like we want them to
believe we want to believe them too much
so everybody wants to believe that
you know
oh tomorrow i can just like
wake up and design a new car or
uh
you know design some new chemical that's
gonna do something really wild or
you know there are all kinds of examples
you can imagine and it's kind of like
that's not really how the world works
uh and it's it's dangerous to think the
world works there because i think a lot
of people screw up their lives
uh you know based on some of these ideas
that's much less compelling though right
think about how sticky some of these
stories are this the stickiness of the
story about the average age of a founder
and an entrepreneur in silicon valley is
27 and a half years old or something
that's
so much more worthy of being pushed
around than it's your mid-40s because
that's what everybody would have thought
you talk about this you say it's the the
counter
counter-intuitive narrative yeah it's so
bizarre think about the fact that the
thing that everybody expects to be the
case work hard in one field get
unbelievable specific knowledge then
branch out on your own once you've got
to the complete top having been a very
good employee and wait wait a long time
until you've got tons of experience like
the fact that the media has managed to
convince us that that is now a
revolutionary story
we were the idiots
but but but yeah i think but i think
like
listeners podcasts
like you can
overrule that like i think when people
have seen that they've been like oh yeah
like they've made different decisions
based on that and you can just look at
these charts and it's like something
about looking at these charts just
clears away the noise a little bit where
i'm just like okay like now i
i know that i'm just being misled by the
media and i'm gonna just look at these
charts and remind myself
uh when i get these one-off stories that
are
uh you know try like meant to confuse me
and so sticky so
i think you can
i i agree that it's like it's harder to
get these ideas out out there but i
think a lot of people have told me from
reading that section that they are like
adopting more of that mindset they're
not going to quit their job tomorrow and
try to do something they've never tried
before and some of them are using this
an optimistic way where there are a lot
of people
who are
45 years old they've been an employee
their entire life
uh and they've had success in that field
but they're just like i'm too it's too
late
like entrepreneurs are
you know do it in their 20 years younger
than me yeah exactly yeah like how am i
gonna compete against all these youngins
and i think
they'll be particularly drawn to the
this idea because now they can be like
well now i gotta think about do i wanna
go off on my own and start my own
business what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you